[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les 4V
François Bayrou au lendemain d'une
dixième journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites on connaît déjà
la date de la prochaine ce sera dans
huit jours le jeudi 6 avril et on se
demande toujours comment on va en sortir
alors hier matin Laurent Berger a
demandé la nomination d'un ou plusieurs
médiateurs hier midi le président et le
gouvernement ont répondu non il n'en est
pas question est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron
et Isabelle borne se trompe en rejetant
cette idée de médiation
ça dépend ce que médiation veut dire si
l'idée était ou devait être de retirer
le texte pour entrer dans une médiation
ça ça n'est pas possible le texte est
devant le Conseil constitutionnel et
c'est dans les 15 jours qui viennent ou
20 jours qui viennent que le Conseil
constitutionnel va dire si le texte est
constitutionnel ou pas
semble qu'il est mais on va arriver qui
ne le soit pas pour sortir de cette
crise non je pense que tous les exemples
que nous avons connus dans l'histoire
récente
dans les 20 dernières années de pouvoir
exécutifs qui ont retiré le texte ou ne
les ont pas appliqués ces exemples ont
jamais été favorables par la suite donc
vous dites
toute main tendue et bonne apprendra
toute main tendue doit être considéré et
on doit tous ensemble c'est ce qu'on
fait d'ailleurs les députés de notre
groupe hier matin on doit tous ensemble
dire on est prêt à discuter à examiner
le très grand nombre de points qui
restent à examiner vous savez que le
sujet qui fâche c'est est-ce qu'on parle
oui ou non des 64 ans et Isabelle borne
a dit je vais voir l'Inter syndicale de
la semaine prochaine mais elle ne veut
pas parler de ce sujet là est-ce que ça
c'est une erreur de 64 ans est dans le
texte je vous rappelle en même temps que
le gouvernement a dit personne ne
travaillera plus de devra travailler
plus de 43 ans pour avoir l'intégralité
de ses doigts de ses droits à la
retraite et donc vous voyez que les
positions sont pas tellement t'éloignées
en vérité
alors il y a cependant
peut-être mais il y a un point qui est
absolument certain dont on n'a pas
mesuré la gravité ou dont on n'a pas su
le gouvernement n'a pas su
aucun des intervenants n'assume mesurer
la gravité la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes et insupportable immoral
scandaleuse c'est quoi cette situation
on paye les pensions avec de la dette
tous les ans une partie très importante
des pensions de retraite peut-être 20%
des pensions de retraite 25% on peut on
peut regarder les chiffres de près
ces pensions sont payées par l'État qui
emprunte sur les marchés internationaux
que j'avais raison alors c'est pas
agréable d'avoir eu raison et de pas
avoir pu faire entendre raison mais
cette
cette situation là il ne devrait pas
vous allez avoir un responsable ni
politique ni syndicale qui s'en
accommode qui l'accepte et je sais que
dans leur fort intérieur et même dans
les discussions
intimes et privées qu'ils peuvent avoir
beaucoup dirigeants syndicaux disent que
en effet ça n'est pas acceptable vous
avez raison quand on regarde la
situation à long terme et dans son
ensemble
dans la situation de crise du moment
comment on en sort est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à un référendum non je pense
que c'était une méthode de référendum je
vous savais que je l'ai défendu puisque
vous avez rappelé mes campagnes
présidentielles j'ai défendu
longtemps l'idée que on fasse le
meilleur texte possible et quand le
soumette à référendum et je pense que
c'était une méthode mais aujourd'hui
tout cela a été engagé acté est venu
dans l'Assemblée nationale dans les
conditions que vous savez devant le
Sénat dans les conditions que vous savez
avec des manifestations très nombreuses
on peut pas changer de ligne à ce point
je crois que on peut discuter et qu'il y
a matière à discuter
et si vous écoutez attentivement au fond
ce que ce que Laurent Berger a dit ce
qu'il a dit c'est qu'il y avait matière
à discuter
peut-être une phrase sur les
manifestations
rarement on a eu des manifestations
aussi nombreuses et responsables en même
temps et aussi peu écouter oui aussi peu
écouter je crois pas je pense que tout
le monde mesure que lorsqu'il y a un
sentiment de d'incompréhension
il faut qu'il puisse s'exprimer dans la
rue c'est ça une démocratie pour le
reste sur le fond
toute décision ou toute orientation qui
reviendrait à remettre en cause la
nécessité je ne dis même pas politique
la nécessité morale élémentaire de
rééquilibrer notre système de retraite
cette nécessité elle doit être respectée
par tous les responsables et c'est le
travail de l'exécutif aussi de le faire
retrait du CPE en avril 2006 voici ce
que vous vous disiez au Figaro nous
sommes dans une république désordonnée
on ne sait plus qui fait quoi il faut
enlever l'écharde qui est dans l'abcès
est-ce que ces mots ne sont pas
parfaitement transposables à la actuelle
de 2023 je ne crois pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on sait qui fait quoi je
pense qu'en 86 vous souvenez il y avait
des désordres qui étaient très très
considérables oui et puis
violente qui qui paraissait échapper au
contrôle
mais le et le CPE c'était pas tout à
fait la même chose c'était une
adaptation du droit du travail pour les
jeunes qui entrent au travail ça n'était
pas la tentative de remettre en
équilibre
un système de retraite qui plombe tous
les ans les plus jeunes du pays
ceux qui vont devoir payer dont personne
ne parle il y a même des gens qui les
embauchent pour manifester comme s'ils
défendait il paraît que le chef de
l'État a trouvé stupide l'annonce
d'Élisabeth borde selon laquelle elle ne
se servirait plus du 49-3 président que
c'est un engage qu'elle Guillaume Darré
nous disait que le climat est délétère
au gouvernement un ministre lui a dit je
suis pas sûr ce gouvernement passe l'été
est-ce qu'il y a un problème Elisabeth
borne François
le le
49-3 je sais qu'on l'a laissé diaboliser
que même parfois les déclarations
multiples et variées ont paru le
diabolisé le 49.3 qui a été établi par
des gens très responsables autour du
général de Gaulle et juste avant avec
des hommes comme Pierre Mendès France ou
Pierre
ce 49-3 c'est une
c'est une précaution de la Cinquième
République d'accord mais ma question ça
veut dire problème avec Elizabeth borne
est-ce qu'il faut changer de
gouvernement
l'idée que on focaliserait sur une
personne les difficultés que nous
rencontrons serait une idée beaucoup
trop facile la politique de bouc
émissaire c'est pas du tout ce qu'il
faut le le on a tous des responsabilités
est-ce que le gouvernement en a oui ou
est-ce que la majorité en a oui est-ce
que l'opposition là oui puisqu'elle
refuse de regarder la situation comme
elle est
elle dissimule il accepte que soit
dissimulé les réalités que nous allons
payer et singulièrement que les plus
jeunes vont payer donc tout le monde a
des responsabilités
à votre micro il a dit lui-même que bon
sans doute on aurait pu faire mieux et
autrement il y a quelques jours de
gorafik et pourtant un site satirique a
tweeté ceci s'agissant du chef de l'État
je vous ai compris mais je fais ce que
je veux s'agissant d'Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que obstination peut-être raison
est-ce qu'il s'enferme est-ce qu'il
s'enferme je ne crois pas c'est bon
j'ai souvent l'occasion de parler avec
lui de la situation je vous écoute et
m'entend au moins ben écoute-t-il c'est
une autre affaire c'est lui qui prend le
quand vous êtes président de la
République il y a une part de solitude
dans la responsabilité qui est la vôtre
mais je sais à quel point il est
attentif à tous ces signes dont nous
parlons et notamment attentif aux mains
qui pourraient se tendre
parce qu'il serait pas suffisamment
attentif justement comme vous
rapporterez un peu tendu avec lui c'est
pas vrai non mais les gens adorent
écrire des romans vous savez si vous
pouvez faire une intrigue à la Westwing
et ils adoreraient ça non c'est pas
cette absolument
2017 pour le coup je veux réconcilier
les Français ça promet en 2017 et en
2022 était la même on va affronter les
problèmes qui se posent dans notre pays
et pas la poussière sous le tapis comme
très souvent les événements ont conduit
les dirigeants à le faire et en même
temps ça ne peut se faire que si on
réconcilie et si on met autour de la
table et il faudra bien que se mette
autour de la table alors une table
officielle à la fin une table discrète
avant des
échanges faut bien qu'on sorte de
l'affrontement dans lequel on est vous
croyez qu'on peut vivre dans un pays
dans lequel le tissu est déchiré au
point justement là pourquoi pourquoi ne
pas accepter la profession de Laurent
Berger de mettre tout ça sur pause de se
mettre autour d'une table et se dire on
remet tout sur la table parce qu'elle
veut pas dire qu'on aurait forme plus
les retraites mais on repart à partir du
moment où un texte a été adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale et par le Sénat
dans le cadre des institutions que le
Conseil constitutionnel va vérifier il
serait
vous voyez bien une remise en cause
profonde ça voudrait dire qu'à l'avenir
aucun texte difficile ne pourrait être
adopté sans que même adopter on le
remette en cause vous voyez bien les
signes que ça que ça que ça porterait
mais
il faut tracer il faut continuer il faut
pas reculer sur la réforme il faut pas
reculer sur les 64 ans et il faudra se
parler après c'est ça il faut pas
changer le gouvernement après et pendant
nous sommes dans une période un peu
d'attente vous dites sur pause la pause
qui est produite par l'effet du Conseil
constitutionnel peut être mise à profit
on peut on peut se je suis d'ailleurs
absolument sûr qu'il y a des échanges
et ce heureusement ça n'est pas des
échanges publics ce sont des échanges
personnels privés et il est bon qu'il en
soit ainsi j'ai une dernière question
François bayraud pendant ce temps le
conseil d'administration de Total
énergie décide d'augmenter de 23% la
rémunération de son patron Patrick
pouillané à 7300 000 euros pour 2022 ça
lui fait un million quatre de plus
d'augmentation sur un an et la hausse
prévue pour 2023 est déjà de 10%. ça
vous inspire quoi c'est normal c'est
bien c'est trop c'est mérité c'est
indécent c'est une discussion que vous
avez sur votre plateau chaque fois que
d'abord la question du salaire des
sportifs
qui sont beaucoup plus importants encore
pour certains que ce qu'on voit là pour
pour le responsable de cette grande
entreprise qu'au d'abord de le problème
des salaires du showbiz
et entrepreneurs
c'est pas le monde dont je rêve vrai
c'est pas le monde idéal dans mon esprit
qui serait un monde beaucoup plus
équilibré mais c'est comme ça que
fonctionne le monde de l'économie donc
vos journalistes économiques qui sont là
et
il se trouve qu'en plus cette entreprise
là c'est une entreprise qui a une très
grande partie de ces activités à Pau et
que je sais ce qu'ils apportent au pays
et si c'était pas de Total ça serait qui
ça serait exson ça serait des
entreprises étrangères qui viendraient
en France commercialiser et on se
plaindrait que constamment la valeur
ajoutée du pays elle part à l'extérieur
et donc encore une fois c'est pas le
monde idéal je suis persuadé que on peut
aller vers un monde plus équilibré
pour autant j'ai pas envie de
c'est difficile parce que vous voyez
bien à quel point il serait simple de
dire mesdames et messieurs ceci est
inaccepte
que mais je dis que cette ces
entreprises là ces grandes entreprises
on en a quelques-unes heureusement en
France elles font partie du patrimoine
du Pays on aimerait que le monde qui se
construit soit un peu plus équilibré que
tout ça merci François Valéron bienvenue
merci à vous messieurs tout de suite